we learned about the use of text view in
the last chapter on hello world
application
the text view is a label which is used
to show text or paragraph on mobile to
understand the concept let us create an
application and add a new text view
apart from the default hello world
as the avd or emulator takes time to
start switch it on before creating a new
application
let us create a new android application
project like the hello world but name it
text view demo
while naming an android application
follow the java coding standards of
using camel case where there is no space
between words
after creating text view demo one can
see the hello world text view by default
if in graphical layout switch to xml
layout to be able to see the xml code
written or generated by eclipse
text view can now be seen
copy paste this below the earlier hello
world text view and change the value of
android colon text attribute to the
required name for it to appear similarly
on the mobile screen for example
android colon text equals quote janus
unquote
if run immediately both the text views
will overlap showing hello world along
with the typed name as the default
layout or the parent tag is relative
layout
while using relative layout specify the
relationship between the two controls so
they can appear on the mobile screen
the text view too with the name janus
should appear to the right of text view
1 which is next to hello world text view
therefore to assign the text view to to
write of text view 1 start with ids
firstly assign ids to controls using the
android colon id attribute
while assigning ids in android to
control
use
quote
at plus id slash unquote
which will be represented as android
colon id equals
quote at plus id slash tv one quote
when quote at id slash unquote is used
it means the id is being accessed in
text view two id of text view one is
used as android colon to write of equals
quote at id slash tv one unquote this
means text view two will appear to the
right side of textview1
run the program to see the output with
the emulator
to place the text view to below text
view 1 change the attribute from android
colon to right of to android colon
layout below and pass the id of text
view 1 as done before
to place the text view to on the left
side of text view 1 write android colon
to left off equals quote at id slash tv
one quote
do not forget to use android colon
layout underscore width to specify the
width and android colon layout
underscore height to specify height of
particular control it is mandatory to
specify width and height of every
control otherwise the application will
crash
for this video the textviewdemo
application will be used
while creating view 2 android colon text
equals quote janus unquote was written
the string in android quote text
attribute is directly passed and it will
show a yellow color underline the yellow
color underline is a warning against
using the hard-coded string and requires
the usage of at string resource
let us understand the concept of string
resource through the earlier discussed
example
the text in first text view is written
as android colon text equals
quote at string slash hello underscore
world quote and on running the
application it shows hello world
exclamation point
this is due to the using of string
resource it is similar to using a
variable and in runtime it will print
the value of the variable and it is
called a key value pair
open the
strings.xml file from res folder and
switch to xml resource tab to see the
code
one can see the string tag in the name
attribute the key for coding is
specified and between string opening and
closing tag the value is specified for
example to add a new string use string
name equals quote course
underscore name
unquote
android developer
course
slash string
do not forget to save the file otherwise
it will not provide any suggestion
change the hard-coded text from text
view 2 to android colon text equals
quote at string slash course underscore
name quote when course underscore name
is used in a code the android developer
course is printed on the mobile screen
run the application to see the change
once a string in
strings.xml file is created it can be
used anywhere in application using the
same string in multiple screens may save
memory and need not be declared on every
screen
create a new application edit text demo
and ensure the avd is running already
edit text is used to take inputs this
means the edit text is an input field or
text field
to create edit text use edit text tag
and specify the input type as per
requirement
there is a range of input types
available with edit text and different
input types can be used as per
requirement such as number
password and email
the hint attribute can be used to
suggest to the user to fill in details
such as name age or password
ensure to specify the id using android
colon at plus id attribute to make use
of that particular control in java code
always assign a unique id to each
control in xml the id acts as an object
for example if an edit text is present
for user name then the input type can be
text if the edit text is used to put the
password
the input type should not be used as the
password will be visible to everyone
hence the input type must be the
password
follow the video and try this process
create a new application check box demo
and ensure the avd is running already
a check box is used for multiple
selections such as one person may have
interest in multiple games using check
box will allow him to select the games
he or she likes
to create a checkbox use the checkbox
tag and specify android colon text
attribute to display the label with
checkbox
follow the video and try this process
specify width and height to checkbox
specify text to display with checkbox
do not forget to assign id to every
control you add to form or screen so
that one can use it later
copy and paste check box 1 to create
another checkbox and change the id and
text
run the application
one can see that both the check boxes
are overlapped
to solve this issue assign layout
underscore below property to second edit
text
run the application again
one create a new application radio
button demo
and ensure the avd is running already
two a radio button is used for a single
selection such as gender where either
male or female gets selected
three to create a radio button use the
radio button tag and specify android
colon text attribute to display the
label with radio button
four add at least two radio buttons with
the code
five if a program is run at this point
and radio buttons are selected multiple
radio buttons can be selected
six
radio buttons are usually known for
single selection
seven
group radio buttons to enable single
selection
eight radio buttons can be grouped using
the radio group tag
nine
follow the video and try this process
create a new application spinner demo
and ensure the avd is running
already a spinner is a drop down list
that is used to display a number of
items
to create a spinner use the spinner tag
specify two attributes
android colon prompt and android colon
entries
attribute android colon prompt specifies
title of the spinner
the title will appear on android devices
with the android version 3.0 or below
the prompt will not appear on devices
with android version 3.1 or newer
versions
attribute android colon entries refers
to the array of string items to form a
list
add all the string items in strings xml
file first
pass the value of prompt and name of the
array to the spinner tag
now follow the video and try the process
add string items to strings dot xml file
using string tag
specify name to every string added to
string xml file using name attribute
add some more string items here
add string for prompt title
then create a new arrays dot xml file
to create an arrays.xml file right click
the values folder under res folder go to
new and select android xml file
a new android xml file wizard will open
enter the file name in lowercase and
click finish
now add a string array tag and add the
string items available from strings xml
file
add items to string array using item tag
now specify prompt and entries in layout
file
and run the application and test the
output
create a new application button demo and
ensure the avd is running already
to add a button in android application
use the button tag
specify the text to be displayed on
button in android colon text attribute
create a reference of button in java
file using find view by id function and
pass the button id as parameter
cast it to button object
now using the button object write on
click dash listener for the button
get the eclipse to suggest and generate
the code using shortcut for control and
space
use suggestions provided by eclipse
but it will show an error as on click
dash listener does not get automatically
imported ensure that the on click
listener is imported to import on click
dash listener hold the cursor on on
click dash listener and click on the
suggestion given by the eclipse for
importing
the eclipse will write the complete
block of code
write logic in on click function
to close the application by clicking the
button use finish function and system
dot exit function
run the application to check if it is
functioning smoothly close the
application by clicking the button
assign the id to button
create button object and use the
reference a button using find view by id
function
set on click listener for button
do not forget to import the on click
listener
write down code in on click function
finish function will close the activity
system.exit function will close the
application
create a new application image demo and
ensure the avd is running already
to add an image and an android
application use the imageview tag
to use images in an android application
place the image and any of the drawable
folders from the project hierarchy
in an image view specify the image
source and the process is complete
follow the video and try this process
create a new application image button
demo and ensure the avd is running
already
to add an image button in an android
application use the image button tag
image button is similar to a simple
button with the feature of placing an
image on the button
to place an image on the image button
use android colon src attribute and
specify the image name from drawable
folder
now follow the video and try this
process
specify width height to image button tag
specify image source using src attribute
run the application
create a new application toggle button
demo and ensure the avd is running
already
to add toggle button in android
application use toggle button tag
toggle button allows user to change
states such as on and off
one must specify two attributes android
colon text on and android colon text off
the text from attribute will be
displayed android colon text on when
toggle button is checked or clicked
otherwise text from android colon text
off attribute will be displayed
in java code right on click event for
the toggle button similar to button and
write code
now follow the video and try this
process
specify text for on and off mode of the
button
run the application
test the output by toggling the button
welcome in this video we will learn to
create a hyperlink in android
create a new application link demo and
ensure the avd is running already
to create a hyperlink in android use a
linkify class
using a linkify class one can create
links for websites maps emails and phone
numbers
to create a hyperlink call static
function add links from linkify class
and pass two parameters pass url
map location
email address or phone number as the
first parameter and the second parameter
is the type of link such as
linkify.web underscore
urls linkify dot map underscore
addresses
linkify dot phone underscore numbers
follow the video and try this process
add two more text view by copy and paste
in java code create object of text view
use set text to set dynamic text in text
view
call a static method add links function
from linkify class and pass object of
text view and type of link as parameters
repeat last two steps for remaining text
views for phone number and email
addresses
run the application and test the output
welcome in this video we will learn to
create a list view in the android
create a new application list view demo
and ensure the avd is running already
to add a list in an android application
use the list view tag
similar to a spinner create a reference
of list view in java
create a string array in java for a list
of items
define a new array adapter for the new
list view and assign it to the list view
now follow the video and try this
process
create a string array for list items
create object of list view
set the list adapter using object of
list view
run the application to test the list
view
to handle the list events use set on
item click listener
now add a message to log about the list
item clicked using log.d function
run the application to test the list
view
select any list item and check the log
for the message
welcome in this video we will learn
about the different layouts available in
an android
a layout is a parent view or group view
which holds the other views on a
particular screen layout
in android we have a linear layout
relative layout table layout frame
layout and absolute layout
follow the video and understand the
differences among the layouts
absolute layout is now deprecated
relative layout is the most commonly
used layout and is default layout in
android
here the root element is relative layout
tag
in relative layout one has to specify
the relation between the controls
layout underscore below will be used to
set the control below another
layout underscore to write of will
assign a control adjacent to another
control but in right side
layout underscore to left of will assign
a control adjacent to another control
but in left side
linear layout is the second most
commonly used layout
here we don't need to specify relation
between controls
if one wants to arrange the control
beside another control set orientation
to horizontal
but if you want to arrange the control
below another control set orientation to
vertical
table layout is used to show the data or
controls in tabular manner
here root element is table layout
and to create a row use table row tag
in absolute layout we have to specify x
and y location for the controls
specifying x and y location may cause
issues
if the screen size is small controls may
go out of the screen and in case of the
large screen size screen will look empty
frame layout is simple layout
frame layout is generally used as a
container
frame layout can also be used to display
videos and camera preview
welcome in this video we will learn the
method to create a web view in the
android
create a new application webview demo
and ensure the avd is running already
to add a webview in an android
application use the webview tag
a web view is used to display web pages
in the android application
hence html pages can be shown in an
android application with a few lines of
coding
to display a web page in the android
application add a web view in a layout
xml file and create the reference in
java code
then use set javascript enabled function
and pass true to render all the
javascripts
set the webview client and load the url
setting load url function
run the application to understand the
process better
set javascript enabled if you have used
javascript
and css in your web page
create a html file in assets folder of
the application
pass the url of the html file to load
url function
run the application to test the output
welcome in this video we will learn the
method of creating a date picker in the
android
create a new application date picker
demo and ensure the avd is running
already
to add a date picker in an android
application use the date picker tag
follow the video and try this process
welcome in this video we will learn the
method of creating a time picker in the
android
create a new application time picker
demo and ensure the avd is running
already
to add a time picker in an android
application use the time picker tag
now follow the video and try this
process
here is a quick recap of what we have
learned in this lesson
how to create ui designs and handle
their events
how one can create links from text
what are the layouts available in
android and which one is deprecated
how easy it is to show web pages in
android using web view